Nightshades are huge family of plants
many of which we eat like potatoes
tomatoes, peppers and eggplants.
Some like tomatillos and ground cherries
have a papery structure that grows
around the fruit.
It forms an air pocket that might
help the seeds disperse like a little
life raft.
This family comes from South America
where its fossil origins
aren't well known.
Previously it was thought
that tomatillos and ground cherries
evolved fairly recently at the time the
Andes rose. But new fossils that look
just like those wrapped up fruits were
recently described by researchers.
These fossils prove that these plants were
around at a much earlier time than
anyone thought, when South America was
still very close to Antarctica
Australia. And even southern South
America where the fossils were found was
warm and wet.
It also means these plants
evolved not just in South America but
likely in Antarctica too before it froze over.
Those are totally different
evolutionary conditions which makes you
wonder what else don't we know about our
favorite foods